they dance they flail they're a big
wacky and awkward way to get your
attention but did you know these tall
boys debuted at the 1996 Olympics as art
meet Peterman Shaw a prominent Caribbean
artist known in Trinidad is the creator
of larger than life dancing puppets
created for Carnival his work made its
way to a book called Caribbean festival
arts and that book made its way to a man
a man on the steering committee of the
Olympics
Peter was commissioned to help create an
unforgettable opening for the 1996
Olympic Games in Atlanta in a moment
nothing short of pure genius Peter
returned to his roots by sketching a
puppet like structure but this time he
turned it into an inflatable air man
that would move and dance just like his
mand puppets for this he had to call in
another artist Doron Gazette an engineer
who happened to be obsessed with
anything inflatable between both men
they were able to accomplish the
seemingly impossible 60 foot inflatable
two-legged dancing men the tall boys
were nothing short of a success after
they graced the Olympics Kazee got a
patent and license the design to various
advertisers now they're everywhere
used-car Lots crop fields shopping
centers you name it so the next time you
see a big ridiculous inflated tall boy
waving at you in the distance just
imagine you're in the Caribbean dancing
along to the drama